I just sorry I just started feeling bad
but you kind of skim from Christmas
aching oh yeah I'm sorry I just really
really bad like halfway through my son
[Music]
welcome back to et at the movie it's a
spoiler section boiler warning spoiler
warning spoiler warning spoiler warning
if you have not seen guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 close out of that tab close
out of that or keep the tab open give us
the view but I'm you I'm going to put a
graphic here and there's a spoilers okay
let's dive in what is your favorite baby
Groot moment it is so hard to choose but
am i telling it to baby Groot yes let
him know so my favorite of your moments
baby Groot was there is one scene where
they are hopping through different
dimensions and it ends and they're all
bogged out in baby grudges projectile
vomit essentially skittles and it is a
problem of mine all my friends make fun
of me but if someone surprised vomits
I'm laughing it would literally from the
first scene to the final post-credit
scene I was like I love this character
so much but if I had to pick a favorite
the first scene and then when she's
trying to get yondu's Finn oh that's and
brings back the body part the phone that
was the funniest friggin thing I've ever
seen James Gunn I was quite surprised
that following on the tail of dr.
strange some of the N beats did feel
pretty similar that planet-hopping scene
I talked about kind of felt like
something out of dr. strange the fact
that star-lord was like fighting a giant
head in the end I know doctors trying to
and I didn't hate it up by any means I
loved it but I was like let's see dr.
strange to break a bit but then again
you can also say that dr. strange pulled
a little bit from Guardian Oh Darla
strand examines - but - climaxes
fighting a giant headed you would think
someone at Marvel would run down the
hallway and be like Oh too much add too
much giant heads yes mr. Kurt Russell as
ego the Living Planet then shrouded in
secrecy secrecy is over what did you
think of ego what did you think of Kurt
what did you think
that whole storyline I didn't read
anything I was keeping myself in the
dark which I recommend you all do and I
was so shocked about that storyline that
if I would have thought about his name
for maybe five minutes probably could
have figured out a lot of what was going
to happen but I didn't I just was like
you know ego whatever I do love that
James Gunn did his own thing he didn't
go off the comics he made it strange he
made it weird which is what we want from
Gardena but the scene will be find out
that ego is responsible oh we don't even
have to say it cuz I know exactly what
you're talking about
and I that broke me I oughta bleed
gasped in my Peter you can't unclear
afterward you didn't hear me kick well I
think the holes but will the whole
theater was just like yeah it was
shocking it was shocking but we do get a
lot of character arts arcs from the
other characters that were really
surprising to me one being yondu not
only to have that from an unexpected
character but with guardians the I am
Groot moment from the end of the first
one is so emotional and now is like the
bar for Marvel emotion and the whole
time I'm watching the movie I'm kind of
like how could they possibly top this oh
they're not going to top it and then to
have that moment come from yondu I was
again surprised this would be surprised
me a lot and made me tear up
especially up until that point we were
getting so much humor even in the most
emotional of moments even in the ego
moments I was like oh my gosh they're
just gonna like make us laugh level time
there's not going to really be that
moment and then it happens it was a lot
I was it was heavy and beautiful and I'm
right now thinking about it P dude after
the sad passing of yon do we get five
post-credits P a I believe a Marvel
first James Gunn you're out of your mind
are you mind but in a good way keep
dreaming I love five I'm like give me
six give me seven give me eight yeah la
might be too and well for the most part
like he tries to play it goofy but then
we actually get a lot on set he
and he was like can we beep on this
thing he said I my credits are stupid
like you don't have to stay from they're
not going to affect the Marvel Universe
and like every one of these is pretty
huge the first one is a pretty simple
one it is Sean Gunn James Gunn the
brother kind of inheriting yondu's
whistle it's just kind of a fun scene
and we know James was coming back to do
guardians three now and it's like oh
we're going to get that whistle again
and we'll probably get more song done
and song sounds great so like great so
post credits scene number two is Dan Lee
so I've done a little bit of diving this
is kind of deep Marvel stuff Stan Lee is
playing an astronaut with a group of
characters called the Watchers the
watchers kind of oversee this entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe plus the x-men
movies plus the blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah when Stan
Lee is kind of talking to these Watchers
and saying I have so many more stories
to share in a way it's kind of like
pulling all these movies together a
little bit I don't know also fans might
be looking way too much into that scene
it could just be a funny little Howard
the Duck bit by that's the current
theory being floated well James going to
say something interesting about the
close friend of scenes that I want you
to hear every tease that we have at the
end of the credits is something that's
meant to become a bigger part of the
Marvel cosmic universe as we move
forward into the next decade and I think
that actually has to do a lot with the
third scene which is we finally know who
Sylvester Stallone is playing
he's star Hawk who is one of the three
thousand guardians who is the original
team of guardians and yondu was one of
the original guardian so they've kind of
adapted kind of bastardized this
original team into a Ravager faction
which is a really fun way to bring them
in right and you get a handful of these
other original ones you get like so fast
you so fast you know theater just like
what
with that without oh I you're watching
the credits and you're like who who is
who who is who yeah tell me more tell me
more reigns is in this right and you
start recognizing two actors and the
character Miley Cyrus is maybe no one
who Michael Rosenbaum who's one of James
Gunn's really good friend yeah James has
said over and over again he wants them
back if that whole crew is coming back
in volume 3 we're doing civil war part
to intergalactic addition which I love
Civil War so maybe I'm wrong yeah I mean
I think Marvel has proven that they can
put a lot of characters right on movie
and it still works but I mean what I've
gathered from what James Gunn has said
it seems like there going to be a big
part of the movie and if anyone can
prove me wrong it's marvelous James Gunn
proved me wrong prove me wrong but we do
know a guaranteed new person coming in
the third edition which is the fourth
credit scene which is Adam warlock the
quick addition is fans have been
clamoring for Adam warlock since the
guardians was even announced so now
somehow Aisha has this cocoon and is
creating Adam warlock and then finally
my favorite post-credit scene angsty
teenage Chris this kind of looks like
teen girl yeah it looks more well give
him a little bit of like an emo like a
Fall Out Boy away panic at the disco
haircut okay but that scene is so great
and he's pissed off and he's playing
video games and he's great James did
talk to us a little bit about groots
evolution and that it's hard to let go
be the group I think it's an awesome
thing for an audience to be able to see
a character actually grow up and to have
kids who saw adult Groot in the first
one and baby Groot in the second one be
able to kind of grow up with him a
little bit as these movies come out
every couple years was it tough for you
to let go baby Groot so fast I mean it
was clearly it was he's going to be a
massive hit yeah overall another Marvel
movie down another one down already can
now another great one on to the next one
on to the next one yeah spider-man
homecoming and then in the fall is Thor
Ragnarok oh my gosh which
looks very guardian see so another
episode of ET at the movies down as well
another episode first episode glad to be
here yeah thanks for tuning in like
subscribe comment all that stuff I'm
supposed to say because if you do that
then we can keep doing more of course
you want to here is where the only voice
in movies that matter
hahaha thank you so much thank you
you